il travaille sur le projet depuis deux
ans la reproduction en marqueterie d'une
ancienne affiche pour le musée des amis
de flavigny sur ozerain pour les
branches après il faut voir aussi si les
petites caisses claires ont été un
minutieux assemblage de pièces de bois
collées sur l'envers le résultat ne sera
visible sur l'endroit qu'une fois
terminé en france nous sommes moins de
dix établissements proposés ces
spécialités souvent s'est associé à du
mobilier ancien mais ça reste un décor
de surface donc tout à fait compatible
avec des décors contemporains le bois
qu'on utilise il est très très faim et
fragile donc pour pouvoir le découper
sans qu'ils ne s'abîment il faut le
maintenir entre deux plaques de médium
qu'est ce qu'on oublie de recommencer
des éléments c'est du travail et la
répétition pour réussir venir découpé au
bon endroit et pour obtenir des pièces
qui vont venir suivante est parfaitement
pour son projet de fin d'année olivier a
choisi de réaliser un élément décoratif
sur un thème végétal avoir énormément de
rage donc ça va être un des plus gros
travail nolwenn d'antan maîtrise l'ombre
âge à la perfection 250 heures pour
réaliser un lutin thème imposé avec
lequel elle a remporté le prix national
2020 du meilleur apprenti en marqueterie
j'écris un cash à partir d'un morceau de
voix que j'ai découpé et j'ai déposé
dessus du sable chaud pour pouvoir créer
ses ombrages donc sur le fond là les
mains sont légèrement en bray sur le bas
pour pouvoir créer les volumes le
chapeau aussi sur ces parties là en fait
quasiment toutes les pièces
belle présence le regard est hélas une
peinture en bois c'est le nom du procédé
utilisé pour ce portrait de gérard
depardieu
on a du noyer pour l'iris de la nacre
pour la pupille et de l'osce pour le
petit reflets qui apporte de la lumière
c'est un travail qui a duré à peu près
six ans à un an de travail pour cette
oeuvre extraordinaire incrusté d'une
trentaine de matériaux plusieurs
essences de bois mais aussi d'autres
matériaux pour les dents par exemple
l'agglo ce soit pas eu photo au sima du
zinc de l'aluminium de la corne aussi le
vinyle une oeuvre d'excellence remarquer
à paris en finale du prix à venir
métiers d'art
[Musique]